serge sarraut et camionneurs de poids
lourds depuis 45 ans et forment
maintenant des routiers est ce qu'ils ne
craignent plus et bien c'est l'arrivée
soudaine d'une voiture devant lui
à partir du moment où une coupe en avant
un but tu vois soit la moitié de l'auto
au fait que tu vois piché lumière qu'est
ce qui va freiner
je sais que tu vas te fier
au zoo qui vont commencer à freiner le
toi tu va ralentir mais des fois on est
tellement de choses à vérifier dans
numéro à chaque côté que ce dernier des
fois impossible
le propriétaire de cette école de
conduite souhaite également une
meilleure surveillance policière et le
problème c'est qu'elle ait pas de
surveillance à ces endroits là haut
niveau policière vas-y pendant les
heures de pointe on sait tous les gens
vont couper la ligne pour éviter un 3 4
minutes d'attentes est venu s'insérer
des endroits qui sont pour eux son
stress sont importants mais pour un
camionneur qui lui est au volant du
véhicule doit réagir c'est pas
nécessairement facile conduire ce genre
de véhicules demandent également une
attention constante
il faut avoir une vision périphérique le
grand qu'un autre parce que quand je
regarde dans mon miroir de gauche et
dans mon miroir de droite trois refuges
dégagé pour jouer en avant aussi serge
sarraut a aussi ce conseil pour ses amis
automobilistes
jacobellis
devrait passer au moins au niveau deux
heures dans un camion hiver super six
réellement la vision compte il admet
aussi avoir eu peur vous savez déjà
rivés sur de fer avec toi mon job
on a ramassé parce qu'il faut comprendre
que nous on rame ans si on a un accident
on ramasse beaucoup de monde
issigeac missionnaire radio canada
montréal